pubs there's thousands of them but this
story is about just four and what makes
them so special they're old this guy
thinks his pub is oldest fair bit older
our rights no way I guess we should look
into this in that case welcome to the
search for the oldest pub in the world
take the floor landlord one welcome to
the old trip dilution
the oldest pub in England so the
landlord boards go back to 1760 but we
know the caves go back to 1070 when the
first castle was built up here here is
the wooden galleon
don't touch it though everyone whose
cleaned it its contour mysterious and
who knows if for the oldest pub in the
world but we sure serve the best part in
the world landlord to you up welcome to
the old ferryboat the oldest pub in
England and possibly the world isn't oh
the last coaster
no no no it is right this pub has been
dated back to 1050 ad but legend has it
it's 500 years older so it's pretty old
pretty damn old we don't have any silly
ships here but we do have a ghost this
pub was built on the grave of a young
girl for Juliet's but one thing's for
sure we do serve the best point let's
hear it landlord 3
welcome to old man inside it's so old we
don't even know exactly how old it is
the records go back to 1251 but the
design of our cellar is before the turn
of the century so you don't know it's
definitely older than the others though
right one ghost we've got way more than
that we've got 53 and one in particular
is way better than theirs
in 1651 James Stanley the seventh Earl
of Derby was executed right here during
the English Civil War ed oldest pub in
the world we think so but one thing's
for sure we pull the best pint in the
world wait I haven't Institution stop
you there there are many who claim to be
the oldest but we are fully researched
and dated as the oldest come on in
you're very welcome chance to Barrett
South is actually older to the town
itself almost all the owners are on
record even back to the original owner
Lewin himself in 900 and he guided
people across the old fort just here
over here in the walls is a letter
answered from the Guinness Book of World
Records have we found it
you have found it and you're very
welcome to Shaun's every bearers gotta
clear that the best beer doors but we
can certainly plan with the best whiskey
in the world this has gotta be the best
excuse for a pub crawl ever
[Music]
you